have you ever been like really uh
guarded protected about what your true
identity is
like you won't appear without damascus
well i mean we were we were in the
beginning
you know in the beginning it was
it was it was cool that nobody really
knew who we were you know and
the reason that we wore the masks wasn't
for anonymity or anything really like
that it was it was all part of this this
artistic vision that we had you know and
part of it was
the shock value but at the same time
it lent itself to
the artistic stylings that we were
trying to to kind of go for like it was
almost like a uniform like we were we
were the anti-image you know like at the
time
everybody was so shiny and pretty and
everybody had their fashion and whatnot
and here we were nine dicks from iowa
and we were like you know what you don't
get our cheekbones or our hairstyle
here's our mask you don't get our
fashion here's our coveralls you don't
get our name here's our name our number
here's our barcode it was basically
almost like an anti-establishment thing
yeah but by anti-establishment you mean
specifically anti-industry right like
yeah guys very much so yeah you guys
operated within the music industry and
vocally and like energetically opposing
the very industry you were in
right right yeah we tried to eat it and
uh we actually threw it back back up so
i'm not sure if that was a good thing or
a bad thing but there you have it right
i almost i was trying to figure it out
like how many [ __ ] masks have there
been cause you change your mouth is it
every album is a different mask
i change my album uh my mask every album
yeah some guys like what they what they
wear so they change it like subtly right
i like to evolve mine yeah clowns well
clowns is i mean he's still the clown
but his changes every album like it's
still a clown mask but it's totally
different yeah yeah the first one was
very like almost happy clown and then
the second one was dark as [ __ ] with the
pentagram and [ __ ] right right right the
the cool thing about the original clown
mask was that was his original mask from
when he was i want to say like 12 years
old oh wow yeah yeah so he keeps that
one protected he still has it and every
once in a while he'll bring it out just
to like [ __ ] with us to be honest and
it's just like oh god you know that's
great man yeah that's like my cheetah
there's only ever been one cheetah print
bikini
right yeah exactly everybody's got that
one thing that like that's the original
and that's you know there's you can have
you know imitations or whatever but it's
not the same man like you can carry it
through the years so what was he doing
with that mask when he was 12. was it
like for halloween or he was just like
he was running around the neighborhood
dude he was a maniac like he hit the
reason and this actually predates me
being in the band
the reason that they started wearing
masks in the first place is because he
started wearing his mask at practice
man like they would be in the basement
like they weren't even in front of
anybody man he would just he would put
that on and it would just bring
a different type of energy out of his
playing and what he was doing so slowly
but surely everybody in the band started
bringing their own masks to practice
like they didn't even debut this look
until after they had really kind of
consolidated it and then when i joined
they actually helped me kind of put
together my first mask
and it was it was crazy man it was like
it was a really cool vibe you know just
it allows you
to just go somewhere really gnarly and
yet
still be
connected with the audience and
connected with the music and but he's
just yeah he's just he's just different
cat man yeah i mean when you put the
mask on are you corey taylor or you just
somebody else completely on stage
it's a little bit of it's
it's it's a little bit of certain
aspects of me you know because i mean
nobody is is one-sided you know
everybody's very multi-like
multi-layered
we all have like different dimensions to
us and that mask and that music
represents a certain side of me certain
events in my life certain things that
i've gone through certain things i fight
to this day you know
and when i take it off i can kind of
come back and be
a well-rounded cory as opposed to just
this
you know nightmarish guy but
it's it's definitely a part of me it's
not all who i am but it's definitely a
part of who i am you know right yeah it
was interesting uh uh
when people say you know they have a
really good personality or this person
the the root word of personality is
persona and persona comes from the greek
uh mask
so i when somebody has a good
personality i just feel like they're
just it's a good mass that they're
wearing for that time and it's not
really who they are you know if
somebody's real charismatic it's
probably they're hiding something wow
[ __ ] scott randolph coming in deep
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats